et maintenant ouais si michel charasse
j'arrache même monsieur sénateur du
puy-de-dôme pas j'aurais dû dire je
trouve du puy-de-dôme
ça va moi ça va très bien vient alors
vous êtes ici pour la nouvelle édition
augmentée de pensées répliques et
anecdotes de françois mitterrand choisis
et présentés par vous et publié au
cherche midi
alors c'est incroyable le nombre de
livres qui sortent sur 100 mitterrand en
ce moment il ya une véritable
fascination mitterrand peut-être pour
boucher un peu de vide alors le climax
ça a été le pèlerinage sur la tombe de
françois mitterrand le 10e anniversaire
de cette disparition
avec tous les fidèles réunis tous les
fidèles
lionel vd - fidèle et des très fidèle
way en tous les cas michel j'ai fait du
bon travail d'abord dans le tgv vous
avait briefé mazarine qui était la vraie
vedette de la journée il faut bien le
dire
vous étiez pas en froid avec elles n'ont
pas du tout donc si toi tu un faux bruit
en réalité tous les sens je vais à
jarnac le 8 janvier qui est la date
anniversaire de la mort du président et
c'est moi qui louent les places de train
pour mazarine et son compagnon et cette
année fabrice médicaments prendre une
aussi chez pour ça qu'on était tous les
90 ça y est il a monté une combine
ferment on va sur la photo on pensait
que vous étiez en train de briefer
mazarine pour savoir ce qu'elle devait
dire ou pas dire non c'est pas le cas du
tout en plus je vais vous dire à la pâte
jeune moi oui alors ensuite comme vous
l'avez un petit peu rapproché de deux
fabuleuses qui est votre votre candidat
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit prise en photo
avec lui non je peux et le besoin de le
rapprocher devant c'est plutôt moi qui
me suis éloigné d'eux parce qu'on a
failli faire piétiner par les
photographes à l'entrée du cimetière
j'ai pas aimé donc j'ai fait le tour par
derrière pour pas être piétiné comme moi
je ça me dit faire assez d'être sur la
photo ça n'avait pas une très grande
importance
donc vous n'avez rien fait pour
l'arrêter de me soupçonner bas on vous
soupçonne un choriste vous savez oui
ensuite j'étais régner l'ordre dans le
cimetière vous avez dit c'est pas une
foire aux bestiaux ici fermez vos
gueules basket parce que les
photographes étaient montés sur les ton
monte sur les petites chapelles qui
devrait coter c'est quand même un
cimetière c'est pas bon elle trouvait
que c'était pas très décent et là au
moment où vous avez rétabli l'ordre
votre portable
ces mauvais genre oui c'est possible oui
alors que ce n'est pas du scandale que
cela fait votre portable quand
la mine a sonné au milieu de ces
cimetières muet nom et sa sonnerie c'est
le curé de camaret bravo la distraction
non non avant votre portable avaient
débrayé ce jour là michel je me ferai
dans sud ouest ils savent ce qu'ils ont
rapporté l'anecdote mais je me souviens
pas avoir répondu au téléphone à ce
moment là pour ça que ça fait chier
voilà j'étais en train de regarder chi
l'ordonnancement des gerbes et cetera
était convenable voilà arrivés des
absents quand même ce jour laver pierre
mauroy pour réalité pas là je crois
qu'il avait prévu une cérémonie à lille
au même aux banques une after y avait
mon roi que t'es pas live et danielle
mitterrand oui sans armes en réalité à
la télévision à la même heure oui je
sais mais chez votre ami drucker et à la
beauté perdre au caire elle a choisi qui
a fait une cérémonie à l après maints
ses plus beaux peu importe il vivait
ségolène qui était au chili ségolène
royal bah oui elle était partie au chili
à part ça tout le monde était là il y
avait quand même du monde mais les les
personnes que vous citez chant pas les
seuls à pouvoir rendre hommage aux mines
amitié rend à sa femme quand même oui
mais sa femme elle ne choisit pas venir
peut-être que les ai pas envie
d'affronter la foule
alors pourquoi ça passionne tellement de
gens mitterrand parce que c'était le
dernier des grands le dernier qui a vécu
la résistance la libération le dernier
call un peu de culture
moi je crois que celle effectivement un
peu tout ça mitterrand disait gouverner
ce n'est pas plaire les français
comprendront un jour vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui les hommes politiques
sont trop sensibles aux aux sondages à
l'opinion publique je pense qu'ils sont
surtout que sensible à ça ouais
et si la france ne va pas bien chez
tucci en partie à cause de ça assez
largement même voilà alors pour vous le
seul finalement qui a une stature
d'homme d'état au parti socialiste c'est
laurent fabius c'était la vie de
mitterrand ça c'était mais aussi voulez
moi je veux pas faire parler les morts
à l'époque c'était la vie demi terrain
je ne sais pas compte tenu de la
conjoncture d'aujourd'hui si ce serait
toujours le même avis c'est malhonnête
de dire comme il a dit
disant que c'était son préféré qu'ils
pensaient que c'était le meilleur
est-ce que ça serait toujours valable
aujourd'hui nous avons à l'époque
c'était le cas vous savez que vous
souhaitez vous oui c'est vrai que je
soutiens parce que non seulement il a
une ligne politique claire mais en même
temps il a l'expérience de l'état il a
été prévu nice il a été ministre à
plusieurs reprises sur des postes
difficiles aux finances à l'industrie au
moment où il a fallu le faire le plan
sidérurgique et c'est un homme courageux
qui a su prendre quand il fallait les
resocialiser bref icaunais l'état il a
gagné à la tête et les jambes
ouais et je peux me permettre et vous
étiez favorable au non à la constitution
oui si je puis dire pour le gt pour le
nom pour pour des raisons qui n'ont pas
été forcément celle de tout le monde
d'abord je n'appréciais pas que on est
signé un traité qui diminue la place de
la france en europe par rapport à
l'allemagne
j'ai toujours considéré que l'europe ne
pouvait prospérer aussi le couple
franco-allemand restée égale on l'a on a
fait l'erreur était content adaptée ça
un jeu coûte
je n'étais pas favorable à l'achat
monsieur d'hommes à voter non rassurez
vous c'est mon voisin j'habite le berry
devant le regard dans lequel est immense
et très près on va passer aux livres
d'abord je dois dire que les droits
d'auteur du livre seront reversés à la
fondation françois mitterrand c'est pas
vous qui les rêveurs berdych gens n'en
mitterrand cambrai mais qu'est ce qui
fonde une peinture l'information aux
consommateurs
nous faisons vivre la mémoire du présent
et surtout nous gérons ce ses archives
alors ce qu'on voit quand on lit ce
bouquin c'est que mitterrand était un
amoureux de la langue française
un perfectionniste de la chose écrite et
qui voulait malgré tout être compris du
plus grand nombre
il est détesté les textes élitaire oui
il s'est forcé de parler français mais
un bon français est un français
compréhensible par tout le monde à
l'ordre
de facebook à iliad et va mais il ya des
choses profondes alors au rayon des
vannes il ya des trucs pas mal quand
même j'ai feuilleté un peu j'ai rien dit
mais le gm du gaullisme consistait à
réveiller la france en endormant les
français oui je sais il faut peut-être
fumée un groupe est avant tout bien être
dans le studio
c'est pas mal sur chirac c'est un type
sympathique dommage qu'il manque de
structures mentales
on n'était pas vraiment de l'année c'est
quand même c c'était l'époque des
combats avec le président chirac même
que ça exacerbe un peu les patients et
puis on est porté à à donner des petits
coups de griffes quoi et après il a dû
vers la fin de son deuxième septennat il
est étonné des propos plus plus
bienveillants à son égard
pas de phrase qui dit prête à réfléchir
mais pas tellement à rire si elle même
qui est bien assez j'ai deux avocats
badinter pour le droit du mât pour le
tordu pas mal pas mal non oui mais non
produit chez effet j'ai fait dix ans de
droit et tout le reste de travers sur
pierre bergé qui revendiquait ses
origines bretonnes il disait à la
bretagne ille et vilaine il a compris
aussi des réflexions plus profondes au
sujet de vichy
disent que tu as et honnête de sa part à
l'époque je n'étais pas encore délivré
de la libye nationale ce qui veut dire
qu'ils reconnaissaient qu'il avait été
soumis pendant sa jeunesse à une
éducation disons un peu maurrassienne
quoi vous savez il ya quelqu'un qui a
dit à ce sujet quelque chose de très
vrai c'est pierre joxe qui parlaient un
jour d'une réflexion qui avait fait son
père et son père qui était qui faisait
partie de l'équipe du général de gaulle
pendant la guerre avait dit mitterrand a
été un vrai pétainiste et après un vrai
résistant il a commencé à me chie dans
les services de vichy mais il n'a jamais
été collaborateur il était c'était pas
la même chose révolution nationale
l'avait fasciné par les trouvais beau il
avait croisé on mais il y avait un
certain nombre de gens qui étaient
fascinés vous savez beuve méry le
fondateur du journal le monde
il a commencé comme professeur à l'école
d'uriage qui étaient les codes de la
révolution nationale a dans l'isère
rexel pétain tout à fait alors bon donc
il y en a qui pouvait être fasciné bon
et puis un jour leurs 43 il a bifurqué
en temps ce n'est plus possible il y en
a marre est ce que c'est parce que
c'était plus possible parce que les
allemands allaient perdre la guerre non
pas du tout c'est parce que le mouvement
de prisonniers de guerre dont il faisait
partie et qui s'était pas engagé a
décidé de s'engager parce que il y avait
un certain nombre de prisonniers de
guerre évadés qui commençait à avoir de
très gros ennuis et puis ils ont jugé
que la politique de collaboration était
il faut insupportable
dans tous les cas il ya un truc c'est
que mitterrand a toujours refusé de
reconnaître la responsabilité collective
de la france pendant cette période
d'occupation ce que j'irais café très
volontiers en 95 au vel d'hiv
oui le président mitterrand refusé de le
faire comme le général de gaulle avait
refusé de le faire pour une raison très
simple c'est que c'est une erreur
historique que mon point de vue parce
que ce qui s'est passé le 10 juillet 40
à vichy c'est que l'assemblée nationale
a délégué les pouvoirs constituants
maréchal pétain pour faire une nouvelle
constitution à soumettre aux français et
qui serait appliqué après avoir été
soumise en français ça c'était le 10
juillet la loi du 10 juillet paru le 11
journal officiel et le 12 au matin le
maréchal a pris sa canne et son chapeau
est allé voir le président lebrun et a
dit je vous dégage et je vous remplace
un coup d'état qui a eu lieu à cause de
pétain et laval le 12 et pas le disent
dans le mitterrand disait c'est pas la
france qui est responsable de la
collaboration
c'est le régime du maréchal pétain et
chirac aly cissé la france oui mais bon
prions chirac à une autre analyse mais
bon ce une erreur historique bien
national gerri il a dit on peut pas être
démocrate chez soi et contester un autre
peuple de décider lui-même de son destin
et il a toujours d'ailleurs réagi
pendant ses deux septennats en
particulier pour la libération des
peuples dans le monde et le droit de
choisir leur destin enfin à l'époque du
début de la réalité car ministre de
l'intérieur quoi à l'époque de la guerre
d'algérie il était ministre de
l'intérieur il et l'algérie j la force
comme mendès france pour l'algérie
française
il avait un gouverneur mais d'assurance
et mendès-france aussi or on a beaucoup
reproché à mitterrand d'avoir été
d'avoir dit qu'il était pour l'algérie
française peuvent paradoxalement sa part
ahmad ezz qui était président du groupe
avaient toutes les réponses la mémoire
est assez sélective et une réaction
la mémoire est très sélective
il y en a une qui est formidable sur la
mort quand il dit je crois aux forces de
l'esprit
on savait nous étions lui est moins très
ami avec jean carmet et quelques temps
avant de mourir jean carmet on a déjeuné
avec lui et jean carmet nous nous dit je
suis fatigué pourquoi vous êtes fatigué
parce que je ne dors plus
allied mitterrand lui-même pourquoi vous
dormez plus mes idées je ne dors plus
parce que j'ai peur de mourir et je veux
pas que la grande faucheuse viennent me
prendre dans mon sommeil
alors on termine leur pas rentrer et
puis 8 8 ou 10 jours après j'en meurs
et j'annonce à françois mitterrand qu'il
est mort une quart mais alors donc il
avait raison la semaine dernière il
était vraiment fatigué d'un puits suivi
de mendy vous croyez qu'il l'a vu et ça
c'est et son son obsession c'est à dire
cette envie de savoir ce que personne ne
savait rien et d'être au fond presque
tout seul à le savoir
alors messieurs après mitterrand va
passer au paysage politique français a
affaire interview paysage politique